I forgot they turn the A/C off
over the weekend.
Why did we even wear
suits today? Nobody's here.
I guess I was sort of
on autopilot this morning.
Most of the time, I'm barely
paying attention
to what I'm doing.
Sometimes I don't even
realize I'm at work
until I'm leaving
for the day.
[ Slurps ] Oh!
That coffee's from Friday.
If we're gonna be trapped
here on a holiday,
let's at least
be comfortable.
Okay, we know basically
what they need to say.
Let's just throw some stuff
out there.
All right.
How about this?
"Hi. I'm Kate,
and this is John,
and we're responsible
for a string of murders
across Central Florida
in 2003."
"Hi. I'm Kate, and this is John,
and for the next few minutes,
try not to imagine us
having terrifying sex."
Hi. I'm Kate,
and this is John,
and we flew here today
on a private fucking jet
to tell you about how the
environment is in trouble.
Are you giving a speech or
guiding a plane on the tarmac?
I'm using my hands
to speak.
Any good public speaker
will tell you
that the hands are
the mouth of the torso.
No one will
tell you that.
But if they did,
they would use...their hands.
Okay. How about this
for a second sentence?
"Hampton DeVille
is going green."
Ohh!
Powerful. Sorkin-esque.
This is really starting
to come together.